it is the spot to shop that highlights
local and small batch makers creators
and curators just in time for the
holidays and here to tell us about a
king Cooperative is founder and owner
Jen Tyler welcome hi thank you for
having me what a great concept tell me a
little bit about what you do at Akin
absolutely so it's a retail in the in
downtown Arts District of Las Vegas and
it features over 30 local Artisans that
handmade Goods or curate different
vintage or plants and different things
like that I love that you do this that
highlight all the talent that is in this
area and we're talking about everything
from jewelry to what looks like baby
clothes tell us about some of the things
that you sell at yeah absolutely so it
really is a Gambit of all the things we
have a lot of great homeware Ceramics uh
tapestry to jewelry like Rings all the
things we also have really cool vintage
your typical vintage of clothing we also
have glassware these are kind of my
favorite little vintage matchbooks so
yes so you can put it with a candle
um yeah it's been really awesome we have
a great network of creators in this town
and to see the quality that you get is
phenomenal tell me a little bit about
how you select your creators yeah um you
know I've been doing this in town for
quite some time I do a thing called
Market in the alley which is a monthly
Market I think we've all heard of that
that's pretty amazing so um through the
years been able to kind of just meet see
and do things with uh with the makers so
it was really kind of just came up with
a thought idea I started outreaching and
at this point now it's like kind of okay
where do we have holes where can we meet
in Phil okay so I'm going to put you on
the spot I want to I want to get some
gifts for a couple of my girlfriends
what would you suggest that I pick out
uh so yeah there's a few things you can
do jewelry we have American metalsmith
she has beautiful silver
sterling silver jewelry and then also
naughty but nice she does a lot of
macrame with jewelry as well we've got
great skin skin care these dishwares are
great these are so cute these remind me
of like the old glasses from like the
80s that my parents used to get and we
would all drink our eggnog out of these
are so cute she's great she also does a
lot of really cool cocktail programs on
her Instagram Kindred Spirits with hers
as well oh
um yeah and then like the candles the
quality the the intention their soy base
they're amazing uh I mean there's so
many options it's hard to choose just
wise I'm not even in the store and I
can't decide this is just here how do
people find your location yeah so if you
go to kencooperative.com that's our
website we're very active on Instagram
and yeah we're on Commerce and Imperial
in the arts district I am following you
right now thank you so much not just for
you know highlighting some of the talent
out there but for helping us what do we
need somewhere to shop we love it thank
you so much for joining us Jen